So the key point is if you're generating keys,
it's really important to use good randomness to generate keys in a way that
makes them unpredictable. And there was a study recently that looked at
public keys. We'll talk about asymmetric crypto in a future unit.
But the problem in generating those keys was not using good randomness.
And this was widely reported in the press--often in a somewhat misleading way--
talking about the encryption system being broken, which it wasn't.
All that was broken was--if you pick bad keys, the encryption doesn't work well.
So you should be careful not to use the built-in random generator
in your programming language. It probably is not cryptographically secure.
There are good random number generators provided by cryptography
libraries--like the Pi-Crypto library that we'll use for some of the code in this class
that implements the Fortuna random number generator.